your show you voice the father on the
show it's an animated show yes uh f is
for family
you voice the father is it based on your
real dad uh
parts of it are based on my dad i wanted
my dad and everybody to be able to sit
down and watch it without you know being
oh my god you put all our dirty laundry
out there but like
there's certain things like that the
catchphrase uh i'll put you through that
effing wall
that that was my dad he definitely said
that he would say i'll put you through
an f and one right now you don't knock
that out i'll put you there
he said it one time when we were outside
which was hilarious he like pointed at
the woods
he was just so used to saying it and
we're sitting there like snickering and
laughing like there's no wall dead
what are you going to do you need a
grandpa
yeah do i need a grandpa oh yeah oh good
i'm available
[Laughter]
it'd be nice it would be great
it would have been nice to have somebody
more a little you know chill you know
singing and dancing around
yeah keep everybody in a decent movie
your dad wasn't dancing in the kitchen
and stuff
no we had a uh i've described my family
to people they said it sounded like lord
of the flies
it was basically my older brother beat
the crap out of me
every day and then i beat the crap out
of my little brothers i would like
practice on them to try to be able to
beat him but he always had like the
psychological advantage
because he beat me for like decades so
by the time i would get on top
winning it just felt weird and i would
get all
psyched out and then he'd get on top of
me i'm like oh yeah this is familiar and
i just cover up
bill you're my favorite guest on the
holidays uh i know
but did your dad have a sense of humor
does he have a sense of humor oh he
definitely had a sense yeah
he had okay this is a good example his
sense of humor one time uh
we had a day off from school just one of
those random wednesdays parent-teacher
thing nobody's showing up
all the adults are boozing tuesday night
that's basically what's going down
so we didn't have school so we were
excited and my dad came home saw us all
excited he's like what are you jumping
around for like oh we don't have any
school tomorrow
we don't have any school it's great we
don't have to do the homework and he
goes ah
you got school we were like no no the
teacher said we don't have school and he
goes no i just heard it on the radio
driving home they switched it you have
to go to school
so you're like oh what a rip-off so we
went upstairs we did our homework he
didn't say anything we went to bed
we got up the next day like a quarter to
six to do our paper routes right he
doesn't say a word
we breakfast doesn't say a word we go
out to go to the bus stop doesn't say a
word finally he gets in his car
he drives down the end of the driveway
rolls down his window stuck his head out
the window waved to us
and drove to work and left us standing
there waiting for the bus
and bus ever come no it didn't we stood
out there for like an hour
looking like idiots the bird boys just
standing there and finally somebody
drove up the street somebody's mom was
looking at us going what are you guys
doing look who
waiting for the bus she's like there's
no school
we're like oh my dad said there was
school right
that was the first time i ever called
him an [ __ ]